welcome to this video I'm playing more
mobile mobile from Norway oh man the
amount of nuvigil flex sarolea far
beyond everything that makes any
statistical sense I guess it's a really
about people being friends of the world
champion okay night f5 this is a funny
line get this from time to time check
queen age form this is a very risky to
play for white yeah as we see black has
an excellent development rook e8 coming
was check f2 hanging g3 Queenie for
losers immediately it's a very very
tricky for I'd I don't know what what's
the best possible move k rook e8
check yeah hard to believe that this
shouldn't be good well I had this before
this is some sort of deja vu moment I
can take here on f2 or threatening
weekly 195 is also interesting 95 to
deform maybe this is the easiest way to
play and then the Knight to g4 simply f2
it's a big problem i had this i had this
before exactly this position probably
against my way also from norway maybe
this is my waist new account and he's
just repeating this in spite the fact
that it is terrible or neither season a
whit whit account really oh it account
ok an IG 4am this is looking very
promising
okay night f two check check I can play
rook you won or not what else
yeah that's certainly not bad but it's
tough to say what's what's best really
I'd like to get all pieces involved
Knight f6 and and and and the like maybe
maybe this a night f 694 something like
that yeah rook e1 yeah just place Bishop
somewhere and to see for maybe and I'm
not sure that this is so great
right see form java if he goes Knight c4
then-rookie one gains a bit in strength
and Aldo Bishop h6 i'm so not at all and
strength caution cautious okay maybe
cover see form yeah again i have not
refuted this crap sorry for my harsh
words but i had exactly the same
position and i forgot how to refute this
this is this is this disposition sorry
no way that white is going to survive
this at least if black is not totally
the optic like like I am so let's at
least not lose on time quickly
I have no direct way to to attack him at
least I don't I don't see it
and maybe even night c8 as possible
I need to get near near the sea three
pawn some some direct attack with 94
it's no use in playing any slow movie I
think
push-up g6 I don't I don't don't really
get it now I'm down on time I guess if
he repeats move so I should I should
accept it I don't believe it though you
will play on brah laughing okay once
there's some way to play on I take on f4
is playing rook at four yeah I ever
really should be I should be shot again
I mean this is a chance but again
someone is playing this this this is
absolutely nonsense variation and I'm
not refuting it okay why am I not
refuting this I really don't know so
night if five is not better okay Queen
inshore Jackie aid should be king d 1 so
it's it's just a slight edge at the
moment according to the comp yeah I'll
this I I cannot believe it probably it
just needs to run somewhat somewhat
deeper for just one pawn I have like
such an overwhelming development that
it's it's absolutely not not possible
that that white should get out of this
so 95 Queen g3 and then I took a
computer once Queenie form Queenie for
is not move that that comes easy to you
because it looks like putting the Queen
in the middle of the board without any
direct threat am
and this is not good this is just about
equal at least the initial evaluation
now it goes down giving black an edge
yeah okay I have an edge here still but
I mean I got the porn back I'm not
material down and should be just better
word I really thought there should be a
direct win so age five is the best
according to the computer here Bishop e3
up this is what this is actually what I
suspected when I went here and there was
this move I thought why not why
shouldn't why didn't I go here this is
probably easier mm-hmm as after the
capture eyes are just underestimated
that I'm getting the porn and with a
dark squares and the dark squared bishop
exchange I can easily develop here the
Kings side kingi 79 f6 yeah this is much
much stronger so here I must play Bishop
to a form now this is c6 is better I am
preventing night be five and here we we
hide this in the strange repetition so I
didn't miss something something totally
winning around here may nice and forward
here there should be three this is a
very key point I need to get the bishops
exchange and then I can can easily
complete development the problem is on
my big advantage is that i have four
against three on the here this form
these four points against three so i've
got a bit pawn pawn more on the
queenside and the three against two are
totally worthless all points that why it
has here a week and can be picked up of
course my age 54 also looks weak but
it's always nicely protected by Knight
f6 so it was ok i just need to play
Bishop e3 and
an excellent shape we can continue the
slide a bit if you want and what is why
it's a White's idea here let's say
activates and then I just go here I can
sometimes attack g3 just an excellent
position alright thanks for watching